ici yannick dumont baron bienvenue à
stockholm en suède c'est l'un des rares
pays en europe où le port du masque
n'est pas obligatoire il n'est même pas
recommandée comprendrait que ça fait
assez spécial quand on habite
on se promène en france là où le masque
il est obligatoire dans les lieux
publics depuis des semaines c'est
spécial donc ne pas le porter ici des
suédois qui ont rencontré ben ils nous
disent que sans masse qui ne se sentent
pas plus vulnérables en fait ils se
sentent bien dans sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici le gouvernement n'impose pas
beaucoup de contraintes au suédois par
contre ils leur demandent d'importants
sacrifices
le télétravail au maximum et de s'isoler
pour une semaine au moindre symptôme
même si ce n'est qu'un nez qui coule ça
les suédois semble bien le respecter
par contre en suède comme dans d'autres
pays en europe
les autorités de santé publique
s'inquiète du comportement des jeunes
surtout des jeunes adultes ce qui
semble-t-il ont tendance à moins bien
respecté ses consignes
[Musique]
il est probablement trop tôt pour tirer
des leçons de cette expérience suédoise
ici les autorités de santé publique
disent que c'est un marathon cette lutte
contre la pandémie c'est par un sprint
il faudrait donc selon les suédois
attendre la fin de la pandémie avant de
pouvoir comparer les résultats entre les
pays